my intentions with this project were not
malicious at all I really was curious
and wanted to expose the weaknesses so
that we can collectively as a community
get better at developing products like
this I'm Leanne Lewis I am the editor
and founder of the fashion robot on my
blog I write about different
technologies that are being used in the
fashion industry I think a lot of people
think of wrist wearables when they think
of wearable tech fitness trackers and
heart monitors and things like that
wearables can be a lot of different
things so I recently saw that Tommy
Hilfiger's Tommy brand launched a line
of smart garments that reward you points
for wearing them the product by Tommy
Hilfiger is a garment with a smart tag
and the smart tag is part of a game kind
of like Pokemon go there are two major
ways to win points through this app one
of them is by getting activewear points
which just means that the chip itself is
moving around during the day and the
second way is to go to these locations
and get points with the points you can
win rewards one of the rewards is to go
to the Tommy Hilfiger fashion show other
rewards are as simple as 15% off your
next purchase what was interesting about
it is that it's so easy to hack I'm
going to show you two ways to tack this
collection
the first one is hardware based so we
picked up one of
Tommy Hilfiger t-shirts with the smart
tag it had a number of weaknesses that I
wanted to expose one of them is that you
can remove it really easily from the
garment so for me that meant that I
could wear it anywhere and I didn't need
to carry around any of Tommy's garments
I could just take the chip with me and
still gain points through that the
second way is by hacking the phone
itself and spoofing your location it's
crazy simple to fake your location
basically I downloaded a app that would
spoof my location on my phone you just
drop a pin on a map pretending where you
are and then on the phone you just
watched a little the little arrow moving
around the map to the place that you
just told it you were here we have the
iPhone 6 with Tommy jeans explore
downloaded it onto it I can see the map
and I can see where it wants me to go to
receive these points so I can go ahead
and drop my pin there click move here
click explore and I just received points
for that visit when I started I was at
the bottom of the leaderboard okay
I just looked at the app and it looks
like I have six hundred and eighty nine
points in the last like two days of
actively hacking this app it has put me
in fifth place and Tommy Hilfiger letter
boy I decided I was going to make a
necklace to hold the chip so that I
wouldn't have to think about it so much
you can basically double your points
every day by having activewear points so
I made a necklace to hold the chip
itself basically I just put it right in
here it closed this
and I could just passively be gaining
activewear points without never thinking
about it and there we go I was pretty
surprised by how quickly I was able to
climb up the leaderboard there was a
woman who had like over a thousand
points and she was at number one and I
didn't really think it was gonna be that
easy to to get there
but in a matter of a few days I saw
myself leap from fifth to fourth to
third to first and that happened pretty
quickly holy cow I am number one on
leather wood that is so cool so after
thinking about this a little bit I
decided that I was getting into a moral
gray area with hacking this device the
thing that scared me about this was it's
a game but in in this game there are
monetary rewards or rewards that can be
exchanged for something of monetary
value so I'm going to stop now that I've
reached the top of the letter board you
know I have no intention of redeeming
any of these points for any kind of
rewards it's not about that at all my
intention for this video series is
really not about breaking the law or
being malicious it's really just to
raise awareness I wish I had a better
answer to the question how could this
thing be better because I do think that
that's kind of a million-dollar question
right now right now is this really
exciting moment where there's so much
exploration in technology and data
science and wearables and that's a
really cool thing
[Music]
hey guys do you know what's Hispanic
Heritage Month nobody you got four more
left people content who's right here